This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For 31 years, Beth Nichols has worked at a homeless shelter in Chicago. This story takes place probably about 25 years ago. In all those years of work, she's witnessed incredible displays of compassion and intense moments of conflict. One day, Beth was in the shelter kitchen making lunch. She could hear people laughing and talking in the dining room. Then, the tone changed.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。31年来，贝丝·尼科尔斯一直芝加哥的一家无家可归者收容所工作。这个故事发生在大约25年前。在所有的这些工作岁月中，她目睹了令人难以置信的同情心展现和激烈的冲突时刻。有一天，贝丝正在收容所的厨房里做午餐。她能听到餐厅里的人们在欢笑和交谈。然后，气氛变了。
And two mothers were at two separate tables and they were angry about something that had gone on among their children. They began shouting at each other. Beth rushed into the dining room. The women got closer and closer together and circumstances got more and more loud and verbally things became more and more threatening. Nothing I was doing was working
两个母亲分别坐在两张桌子旁，她们因为孩子们之间发生的一件事而感到生气。她们开始互相大喊大叫。贝丝冲进了餐厅。两个女人越靠越近，情况变得越来越吵闹，言语上的威胁也越来越升级。我做的任何事情都不起作用
and I felt that we had reached a point where I was not even present in their minds, like it was just the two of them. And as they were just inches from coming to blows, I had a washcloth in my hand from the kitchen and there was not a moment of premeditating this at all. I threw the washcloth up in the air and yelled, go for it! And they dropped their arms and they turned and stared at me with their mouths open. And everybody in the dining room was like, what? And it worked. By suggesting that she was flagging the start of a race, Beth turned a tense moment into a joke.
我觉得我们已经到了一个地步，在她们的心中我甚至都不存在了，就像现场只有她俩一样。就在她们即将大打出手的前几英寸，我手里拿着一块从厨房拿出来的抹布，这完全不是事先预谋好的。我把抹布往空中一扔，大喊一声：“加油上吧！”她们放下了手臂，转过身来，张大嘴巴盯着我。餐厅里的所有人都觉得：“什么情况？”结果成功了。贝丝通过暗示自己是在为一场赛跑做标志，把一个紧张的时刻变成了一个笑话。
Yeah, but it actually was effective strangely enough. Humor can diffuse tension and bring us together like nothing else. It's how we make friends, bond with co-workers, get our entertainment. And yet, humor is often missing in many parts of our lives. We lose our sense of humor. We stop smiling and laughing. This week on Hidden Brain, the global humor cliff and how making a joke is like exercising, meditating,
是的，但说来也奇怪，它确实很有效。幽默能够化解紧张气氛，把我们凝聚在一起，这是其他任何东西都无法比拟的。这是我们结交朋友、与同事建立联系、获得娱乐的方式。然而，在我们的许多生活中，幽默往往是缺失的。我们失去了幽默感。我们停止了微笑和欢笑。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨全球幽默断崖，以及为什么开玩笑就像是锻炼、冥想
and having sex all at the same time. Think about the smartest person you know. Maybe it's your mom or a teacher. Now think about the most accomplished person you know. It has to be someone you know personally, not someone you've seen on TV. Maybe a friend who's a scientist. Now think about the funniest person you know. When I do this, I find it takes me a moment. I know a lot of smart people. I've talked to a lot of accomplished people on the show. But funny people? Not so much. At the Stanford Business School, behavioral scientist Jennifer Acker has been asking a serious
和做爱同时进行。想想你认识的最聪明的人。也许是你妈妈或一位老师。现在想想你认识的成就最高的人。必须是你个人认识的人，而不是你在电视上看到的人。也许是个当科学家的朋友。现在想想你认识的最搞笑的人。当我这样做时，我发现这需要我花一点时间。我认识很多聪明的人。我在节目中采访过许多取得巨大成就的人。但搞笑的人呢？没那么多。在斯坦福商学院，行为科学家詹妮弗·阿克一直在探讨一个严肃的
question. Why is humor in short supply in many of our lives? Jennifer Acker, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's so nice to be here. Some years ago, Jennifer, you were talking with a group of second graders and you asked them, who is the funniest person you know? Can you describe the scene to me and tell me what they told you? I was in the classroom of my daughter, Tais Lone, at the time she was in second grade. So I was teaching a little module on Power of Story, which I also teach at Stanford Business
问题。为什么在我们的很多生活中幽默总是供不应求？詹妮弗·阿克，欢迎来到《隐藏大脑》。很高兴来到这里。詹妮弗，几年前，你曾与一群二年级学生交谈，你问他们：你认识的最搞笑的人是谁？你能给我描述一下当时的场景，并告诉我他们对你说了什么吗？当时我在我女儿泰丝·龙的教室里，她那时上二年级。所以我正在教一个关于“力量的故事”的小模块，这也是我在斯坦福商学院教授的内容。
School. I had finished the segment early because, you know, these second graders, they're pretty damn smart. And so I decided to take the last five minutes of filler time and say, who thinks they're funny? Everyone's hands shot up. Then I said, who is the funniest person that you know? Everyone's hands shot up again.
我提前完成了这部分教学，因为你知道，这些二年级的孩子们，他们真的是聪明得要命。所以我决定利用最后五分钟的填补时间说：“谁觉得自己很搞笑？”所有人的手都举了起来。然后我说：“你认识的最搞笑的人是谁？”所有人的手又都举了起来。
I called on all 30, 29 of them, said they're dad or brother. I was horrified. So I went home that night and I talked to my family of three kids, Teah, Cooper, Devon, my husband, Andy. And I said, can you believe that 29 of these 30 kids all said their dad or brother, everyone looked down quietly, not saying a word. And I said, excuse me. And so Teah chirped up, you know,
我点名了所有30个孩子，其中29个说他们的爸爸或兄弟。我当时吓坏了。所以那天晚上我回家后，跟我的三个孩子——泰亚、库珀、德文，还有我丈夫安迪谈了这件事。我说：“你们敢相信吗？这30个孩子里有29个都说他们的爸爸或兄弟。”每个人都默默地低下头，一言不发。我说：“请问？”于是泰娅小声地插话道：
quietly, yes, dad is the funniest, then comes us, then our dog, and then you. You were behind the dog. I was decidedly behind the dog. decidedly behind the dog. Jennifer can laugh about it now, but she also felt sad that she was seen as unfunny. Was that how people thought of her? She noticed of course the gender differences. The men were seen as funny, the women less so. Why was that? As she started to think about humor as a topic of research,
“嗯，爸爸最搞笑，然后是我们，接着是我们的狗，最后才是你。”你排在狗后面。我绝对排在狗后面。绝对排在狗后面。詹妮弗现在可以拿这件事开玩笑了，但她同时也感到难过，因为自己被视为一点也不搞笑。难道人们就是这么看她的吗？她当然注意到了其中的性别差异。男性被视为搞笑的，女性则不然。为什么会这样？当她开始把幽默作为研究课题时，
she also stumbled on something else. The polling company Gallup found that when it came to humor and laughed her, something was happening to both men and women around the world, starting around age 23. We lose our sense of humor. We stop smiling and laughing. So Gallup asked people in 166 countries, the simple question, did you smile or laugh yesterday? So for those who are 16, 18, 20, the answer
她还偶然发现了另一件事。民意调查公司盖洛普发现，当谈到幽默和笑声时，无论男女，在世界各地，从大约23岁开始，某种情况正在发生。我们失去了幽默感。我们停止了微笑和欢笑。因此，盖洛普向166个国家的人们提出了一个简单的问题：你昨天笑过或微笑过吗？所以对于那些16岁、18岁、20岁的人来说，答案
largely is yes. And then around 23, the answer becomes no. And we don't start laughing again until 70 or 80. Put another way, the average four year old lasts 300 times a day. It takes the average 40 year old to and a half months to laugh that many times. So yes, what we call a global humor cliff. And this was research that was done before the global pandemic. So just as people are entering the workforce, the laughter goes out of their lives. I mean, it's a pretty grim picture of what it's like to be a working age adult Jennifer.
基本上是“是的”。然后到了23岁左右，答案就变成了“不是”。直到70岁或80岁，我们才又开始笑。换句话说，平均一个四岁的小孩一天要笑300次。而一个普通四十岁的人需要两个半月才能笑那么多次。所以，是的，这就是我们所说的“全球幽默断崖”。而且这项研究是在全球大流行之前进行的。因此，就在人们步入职场时，笑声从他们的生活中消失了。我的意思是，对于一个工作年龄的成年人来说，这幅画卷显得相当冷酷，詹妮弗。
It is. We find that people go into the workforce and they basically stop smiling and laughing or behaving in ways that feel authentic. Part of it is that, you know, they go into work and they think they have to be serious or the risks of humor seem too great. Or by time they've decided they aren't funny nor want to be funny because that's inefficient and it belies their goals at work.
确实如此。我们发现人们进入职场后，基本上就停止了微笑和欢笑，或者不再表现出那种感觉真实的行为了。部分原因在于，你知道，他们进入工作岗位后认为自己必须严肃认真，或者幽默带来的风险看起来太大了。或者等他们决定自己既不搞笑也不想搞笑时，因为那效率低下，而且违背了他们在工作中的目标。
I'm wondering if this research speaks to your own experience, Jennifer. If I had met you at age 4 or age 8, how much did you laugh? When I was a four-year-old, I was about to hit the stand-up circuit. You know, that would have been some good times. You know, by 16 and 18, I still had a very silly sense of humor. I remember, you know, times with my high school friends where we would, you know, dress up for birthday parties and it was a very easy time to laugh and be silly. And then I moved into college where I had this sense of humor kind of dry and dark and
我想知道这项研究是否符合你自身的经历，詹妮弗？如果我在你4岁或8岁时遇到你，你当时笑得有多频繁？当我4岁时，我差不多快要进军单口喜剧界了。你知道，那会是一段美好的时光。你知道的，到了16岁和18岁时，我仍然有着非常幼稚的幽默感。我记得，你知道的，我和高中朋友在一起的时光，我们会，你知道的，为了生日派对精心打扮，那是很容易开怀大笑和傻乐的时期。然后我上了大学，在那里我的幽默感变得有点干瘪和阴暗，
I basically had a humor fail. One of my friends said that, you know, my humor hurt her feelings and I stopped making jokes around 23. And would you say that you have experienced the same humor cliff in the year since 23 that in some ways when you think back on what you did yesterday, can you remember times when you laughed on most days? Well, so getting a PhD doesn't require a sense of humor, nor does publishing academic articles scream, you know, throw in a laugh line. So yes, I would say by the time I started my PhD, I had solidly lost a sense of humor
我基本上遭遇了一次“幽默滑铁卢”。我的一位朋友说，你知道，我的幽默伤害了她的感情，我在23岁左右就停止开玩笑了。你会说你在23岁之后的岁月里也经历了同样的“幽默断崖”吗？在某种程度上，当你回想昨天做过的事情时，你能记起大多数日子里自己笑过的时候吗？嗯，所以获得博士学位并不需要幽默感，发表学术论文也完全没有那种“加入一个笑点”的氛围。所以是的，我可以说，当我开始攻读博士学位时，我已经彻底失去了幽默感，
and definitely the propensity to laugh easily with colleagues. Now, they're very smart people. We're just not talking humor being a priority. You know, it's interesting at some point in my own life, I feel I went from a world where people laughed at jokes to a world where people would just say that's funny when someone said a joke instead of laughing at the joke. That's right. Or on text, just LOL, that's it, done.
也绝对失去了与同事轻松欢笑的倾向。现在，他们都是非常聪明的人。我们只是不把幽默当成首要任务。你知道，有趣的是，在我自己人生的某个阶段，我感觉自己从一个人们会因笑话而发笑的世界，变成了一个当有人讲笑话时，人们只会说“真好笑”而不是真正去笑的世界。没错。或者在短信里，只发个LOL（大笑），就这样，结束了。
Exactly, yeah. So, you know, we won't hurt the phrase act professional. When you join a new company or you enter a workplace, you're supposed to behave in a certain way, no fooling around, no lounging about, and of course, no joking around. We've actually written the humor cliff into employee manuals. Absolutely, you know, it's interesting. This idea of bringing your whole self to work or how you act on weekends could be something that you would bring to work is something that has been underscored for a long time. What's interesting about the days in which we're living now with remote work
确实，是的。所以，你知道的，我们不会去打破“表现得专业”这个词组。当你加入一家新公司或进入一个工作场所时，你本该以某种方式行事，不能胡闹，不能游手好闲，当然也不能开玩笑。我们实际上已经把“幽默断崖”写进了员工手册里。绝对的，你知道，这很有趣。这种“把完整的自我带到工作中”或者“你在周末的行为方式也可以带到工作场所”的想法，长期以来一直被强调。现在我们所处的远程办公时代的有趣之处在于，
is that things are shifting in very significant ways. You know, a lot of what we're talking about is not necessarily about cracking jokes. It's much more about being human. So you point out that even though many people believe that the way to appear serious and professional in the workforce is not to engage in a lot of jokes, a lack of humor often points not to seriousness
事情正在发生非常重大的转变。你知道，我们讨论的很多内容不一定关乎讲笑话。它更多的是关于展现人性。所以你指出，尽管许多人认为在职场中显得严肃和专业的途径就是少开玩笑，但缺乏幽默感往往并不意味着严肃，
as much as a lack of confidence. And we see that many smart and serious people often are able to deploy humor to great effect. I wanna play you a short clip of former Secretary of State, Madeline Albright, talking about diplomacy and her fashion choices in the aftermath of the first Persian Gulf War. And so all of a sudden a poem appeared in the papers in Baghdad comparing me to many things,
而更多地意味着缺乏自信。我们看到许多聪明且严肃的人往往能够运用幽默取得巨大的效果。我想播放一段前国务卿马德琳·奥尔布赖特的短片，她在片中谈到了波斯湾战争结束后她的外交政策和时尚选择。突然之间，巴格达的报纸上出现了一首诗，把我比作很多东西，
but among them an unparalleled serpent. And so I happened to have a snake pin. So I wore it when we talked about Iraq. And when I went out to meet the press, they zeroed in and said, why are you wearing that snake pit? I said, because said I'm saying compared me to an unparalleled serpent. And then I thought, well, this is fun. So I went out.
但其中之一是“一条无与伦比的毒蛇”。碰巧我有一枚蛇形胸针。所以当我们讨论伊拉克问题时，我就戴着它。当我出去会见记者时，他们把镜头对准我并问：“你为什么要戴那枚蛇形胸针？”我说：“因为他们把我比作一条无与伦比的毒蛇。”然后我想，嗯，这挺有意思的。于是我出去，
And I bought a lot of pins that would, in fact, reflect what I thought we were going to do on any given day. What was the message she was trying to send, Jennifer? Exactly what we just talked about, that she, A, a you know could read the room and know what was implicitly or explicitly being said about her but also be just showing up as a human when people interact with her as secretary Madeline Albright they act in one way but when she used these pins to break a smile that would actually allow them to interact with her in a very different
买了很多胸针，这些胸针实际上能反映出我认为我们在任何特定的一天里要做的事情。詹妮弗，她当时想传达的信息是什么？正如我们刚才所讨论的，她A，你知道的，能够审时度势，知道别人对她明里暗里说些什么，但同时B，也是作为一个真实的人出现。当人们与国务卿马德琳·奥尔布赖特互动时，他们会以一种方式行事；但当她用这些胸针打破严肃的气氛时，实际上能让他们以一种截然不同的方式与她互动，
way, one where she was much more human. And years later, Shankar, upon discovering that Russians had bugged the State Department, she wore this enormous bug pen to her meeting with Russian foreign minister, and he knew immediately that the jig was up. And it was great, too, because with the press, you know, she would, on good days, she would wear butterflies and balloons. And then on bad days, she would wear, you know, carnivorous animals and spiders. So when people say, how are you doing?
那是一种她更具人情味的互动方式。几年后，尚卡尔，在发现俄国人在国务院安放了窃听器后，她戴着这枚巨大的虫子胸针去会见俄罗斯外长，而对方立刻明白大势已去。这也太棒了，因为面对记者，你知道的，在顺利的日子里，她会戴上蝴蝶和气球。而在糟糕的日子里，她会戴上，你知道的，食肉动物和蜘蛛。所以当人们问：“你最近怎么样？”
She could just say, read my pants. You tell the story of how Madeleine Albright once charmed a Russian diplomat during some high stakes negotiations. Can you describe what happened? Tell me that story. Absolutely. So, Secretary Albright was preparing for a summit in the Philippines. One of the diplomatic duties she was asked to perform was a skit. And this is apparently a tradition that happens during a formal dinner gala on the final evening of the summit. The United States always does this very badly. There was a counter-part in the Russian government.
她就可以直接说：“看我的胸针。”你讲过马德琳·奥尔布赖特如何在某次高风险谈判中迷倒了一位俄罗斯外交官的故事。你能描述一下当时发生了什么吗？给我讲讲那个故事。没问题。当时，奥尔布赖特国务卿正准备前往菲律宾参加峰会。她被要求履行的外交职责之一是表演一个小品。这显然是峰会最后一晚正式晚宴晚会上的一项传统。美国人总是把这个环节搞得很糟糕。当时俄罗斯政府里有一位对等官员。
And so what she did was she invited him to sing a duet with her. So this night before the dinner, they went, they had all this vodka and they rehearsed this skit that they were gonna do together. Basically, instead of singing West Side Story, they performed together East West Story. And that's how something that was going to be a disaster turned out to be a lot of fun. Besides being a lot of fun, it seems like there was also a certain strategy in her deployment of humor.
于是她做的是，她邀请他与她合唱一曲。所以在晚宴的前一天晚上，他们去了，喝了好多伏金酒，并排练了他们将要一起表演的小品。基本上，他们没有唱《西区故事》，而是共同表演了《东西方故事》。就这样，一件本来会是一场灾难的事情，最后变得非常有趣。除了非常有趣之外，似乎她在运用幽默时也有着某种策略。
That it was more than just simply getting a laugh. It was actually being able to get to some results and diplomacy that she might not have been able to get to otherwise. That's exactly right. And so the ability to shortcut negotiations and be able to not just crack a smile, but be able to expedite the outcomes that she wanted to drive to was significant. And notice what she did there, right? She co-opted someone who did have an antagonistic point of view to be on our team.
这不仅仅是为了博得一笑。实际上，它是为了在外交上取得一些原本可能无法取得的成果。完全正确。因此，能够走捷径完成谈判，不仅能博得一笑，还能加快她想要推动的结果，这是意义重大的。注意她在那里做了什么，对吧？她把一个本具有敌对观点的人拉拢到了我们的团队中。
And that's what we find happens a lot of times when people use humor strategically and thoughtfully. It's basically creating a more inclusive environment where you feel like you're on the same team. Right. And in some ways, it's hard if you co-opt an opponent or an even an enemy to make a joke with you. It's very hard to feel like this person is still your opponent or it's still your enemy. Once you've laughed with someone, it feels like you bonded with them.
而这就是我们发现当人们战略性且深思熟虑地使用幽默时经常发生的事情。这基本上创造了一个更具包容性的环境，让你觉得你们在同一个团队里。没错。在某种程度上，如果你拉拢一个对手甚至敌人和你一起开玩笑，这很难办。一旦你和某人一起开怀大笑，你很难觉得这个人仍然是你的对手或是你的敌人，你会觉得你和他们建立了联系。
That's exactly right. And, you know, think about the long-term impact of this, right? When you interact a second time, it doesn't even matter if it's like years later. You're able to recall that East West song moment. So the opportunity to have a callback, which, you know, is simply referring to a previous time where people laughed together and be able to rekindle that memory has all sorts of positive impacts on the relationship and on outcomes moving forward. So it has a ripple effect. Yeah. People have noted for many years that one of the things that's happened in Washington is
完全正确。而且，你知道，想想这带来的长期影响，对吧？当你进行第二次互动时，哪怕已经是好多年后也无所谓。你能够记起那个演唱东西方歌曲的时刻。因此，“回调”的机会——你知道，这只是指人们曾经一起开怀大笑的过往，并且能够重新点燃那种记忆——对双方的关系以及未来的结果都有各种各样的积极影响。所以它具有涟漪效应。是的。多年来，人们一直注意到，华盛顿发生的事情之一是，
that many members of Congress do not stay in Washington. They don't live in Washington. They live in their home district, which didn't used to be the case. It used to be that many people who came to Washington actually lived in Washington. But living in Washington has gotten such a bad reputation that most members of Congress go home for long weekends and for vacations. And so they don't really, they're not hanging out with one another in the same space. And so they're not going to social locations together. don't really, they're not hanging out with one another in the same space, and so they're not going to social locations together. Presumably, they're also not laughing together
许多国会议员并不常驻华盛顿。他们不住在华盛顿。他们住在自己的选区，过去可不是这样的。过去，许多来到华盛顿的人实际上就住在华盛顿。但住在华盛顿的名声变得如此糟糕，以至于大多数国会议员会在长周末和假期回家。因此他们真的没有在同一个空间里聚在一起，所以他们不会一起去社交场所。他们真的没有在同一个空间里聚在一起，所以他们不会一起去社交场所。据推测，他们也不像20或30年前那样经常
as much as they might have done 20 or 30 years ago, and it makes you wonder how much of the poison that we see in sort of polarized discussions is because people actually haven't spent some time sitting down together and having a good laugh. I completely agree. You think about the increasing element of divisiveness, of social isolation, and you also compare that
一起开怀大笑，这让人不禁好奇，我们在某种极化讨论中看到的那些毒性，有多少是因为人们实际上并没有花时间坐在一起开怀大笑。我完全同意。你想想那种日益加剧的对立、社会孤立的元素，然后再将这些与一起开怀大笑的科学益处，或者像马德琳·奥尔布赖特国务卿那样展现真我进行对比，它们的影响是重大的。我要指出的是，尽管我们没有物理上的亲密接触，但我们还有其他方法来培养幽默感。没有什么比一点乡村幽默更让我喜欢的了。例如，罗纳德·里根以拥有一系列标志性的故事或笑话而闻名，他把这些写在一张小纸条上。他一直随身带着它们。
with the scientific benefits of laughing together, or showing up in ways like Secretary of Mental and Albright did, they are significant. I will note there are other ways that we can cultivate humor even though we're not physically close. There's nothing I enjoy more than a little country humor. For example, Ronald Reagan was known to have essentially a signature story or jokes that he kept in a just like a little piece of paper. He kept with them all the time.
拥有你的最大好处之一就是我可以讲一个农场笑话。所以这些都是他在发表大型演讲甚至在电话中都会顺口说出的单句笑话。它们无一例外总是大获成功。然后他就会把那个笑话或故事的标题写下来。那里有个老堪萨斯农夫。他有一块小溪底的土地，
One of the great things about having you here is that I get to tell a farm joke. And so these are one-liners that he would say in context where he was giving big speeches or even on the phone. And they would inevitably always crush. And then he would just write down what the title of that joke or story was. It was an old Kansas farmer there. He had a piece of creek bottom land
这块地从来没有被开发过。那里全都是老堪萨斯农夫。他有一块小溪底的土地，这块地从来没有被开发过。这里到处都是岩石和灌木丛，他开始着手清理并耕耘这里的土壤，还在那里种了一个菜园。这里真的变成了一处菜园，他对自己的成就感到非常骄傲。于是某个星期天早上，他请牧师顺道来看看，牧师看了一眼便说：“哦，这太棒了。”他说：“这是我见过的最大的西红柿。赞美主。”
that had never been developed at all. It was all old Kansas farmer there. He had a piece of creek bottom land that had never been developed at all. It was all rocks and brush and he started in on it, clearing it and cultivating the soil there and he planted a garden. It really became a garden spot and he was pretty proud of what he'd done. So one Sunday morning he asked the preacher if he wouldn't stop by to have a look and he took one look and he said, oh, this is wonderful. He said, these are the biggest tomatoes I've ever seen. Praise the Lord.
那些甜瓜，他说：“主真的保佑了这个地方。”看看那玉米的高度。他说：“上帝真的太好了。”老农夫听着这一切，变得越来越局促不安。最后，他冲口而出：“牧师，我希望你能看看上帝自己独自经营这块地时的样子。”这种简单而经典的幽默使用方式，以及理解幽默能够化解敌意并推动目标前进，是如此重要。当我们回来时，我们将探讨幽默的心理影响，并检验专业喜剧演员使用的技巧。
Those melons, he said, the Lord really has blessed this place. And look at the height of that corn. He said, the God has really been good. And the old boy was listening to all this and he was getting more and more fidgety. And finally, he blurted out reverend. I wish you could have seen it when the Lord was doing it by himself. That that simple classic way of using humor and understanding that humor can disarm and and move goals forward is so important. When we come back we explore the psychological effects of humor and examine techniques used
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。行为科学家詹妮弗·阿克研究了她所谓的“幽默断崖”的影响。我们中的许多人在二十出头步入职场时，笑声急剧减少。在她的新书《严肃幽默》（与内奥米·巴格达纳斯合著）中，詹妮弗探讨了幽默断崖的影响。失去多年的笑声，不仅仅意味着错过了乐趣。我们错失了幽默带来的所有心理和职业益处。詹妮弗，对许多人来说生活很艰难。
by professional comedians. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Behavioral scientist Jennifer Aakher has studied the effects of what she calls the Humor Clif. Many of us sharply cut back on laughing as we joined the workforce in our early 20s. In her new book, Humor Seriously, co-authored with Naomi Baghdanas, Jennifer examines the effects of the humor cliff. Losing out on years of laughter means more than missing out on fun. We miss out on all the psychological and professional benefits of humor. Jennifer, life is tough for lots of people.
它充满痛苦、逆境，有时甚至是悲剧。其中许多人可能会说：“斯坦福教授让我多笑笑倒容易，但我生活中找不到多少可笑的事情。”对于幽默在我们审视自身问题时所能发挥的作用，你会对他们说些什么？这是一个很好的问题。然而现实是，我们无法承受没有幽默感的代价。你知道，我们正处于心理健康危机的之中。抑郁症发病率空前绝后，社会孤立更是雪上加霜，让本已
It's filled with pain, with adversity, sometimes with tragedy. And a lot of these people might say, it's all well and good for a Stanford professor to tell me to laugh more, but I don't find much in my life to laugh about. What would you say to them about the role that humor can play in giving us perspective about our own problems? It's such a good question. The reality though is that we can't afford to be humorless. You know, we're in the midst of a mental health crisis. Rates of depression are unparalleled and social isolation is piling on to increasingly
充满压力的工作环境更加恶化。我们与家人和环境一起工作，那里的压力很大，这些一点也不好笑。然而，你和你公司最好的自我，可能正是幽默。是的，你知道，这很有趣。我认为我们很多人把轻松的重要性与它会削弱严肃性的观点混淆了。在某种程度上，当你谈论非常严肃的问题时，你不能拥有轻松感。但当你想到最好的追悼会时，比如说，当某人刚刚去世，
stressful work conditions. We're working with our families and environments where stress is high and none of this is funny. And yet, your and your company's greatest self just might be humor. Yeah, you know, it's interesting. I think a lot of us confuse the importance of levity with the idea that it undermines the issue of gravity. That you can't, in some ways, have levity when you're talking about issues that are very serious. But when you think about the best, you know, memorial services, for example, when someone has just died,
许多最好的追悼会通常都带有幽默的成分。我想到的是篮球巨星沙奎尔·奥尼尔在科比·布莱恩特去世后发表的那篇令人难以置信的悼词。我想给你播放一小段他的悼词。科比赢得我尊重的那天，队员们都在抱怨。他说：“沙克，科比不传球。”我说：“我去跟他说。”我说：“科比，团队里没有‘我’这个字。”
many of the best memorial services often have an element of humor. I'm thinking about the incredible eulogy that the basketball star, Shaquilo Neal, offered after the death of Kobe Bryant. I want to play you a short excerpt from his eulogy. The day Kobe gave my respect was the guys were complaining. He said, Shae, Kobe's not passing the ball. I said, I'll talk to him. I said, Kobe, there's no iron team.
科比说：“我知道，但里面有‘我这个混蛋’。”所以我猜詹妮弗，会有人说科比在直升机坠毁中身亡绝不是开玩笑的事。但当你听沙克的话时，你听不到对那个笑话的任何不尊重。如果有的话，你听到的是深情，你听到的是爱。
And Kobe said, I know, but there's an in me and that f***ing. So I suppose Jennifer that someone could say, Kobe's death in a helicopter crash is no laughing matter. But when you listen to Shack, you don't hear any disrespect in that joke. If anything, you're hearing affection, you're hearing love.
绝对是的。我们书的结尾是由迈克尔·刘易斯撰写的。他在后记中以这句话结尾：“当幽默存在时，爱也就不远了。”当幽默存在时，爱也就不远了。顺着你的观点，你知道，这确实如此，当我们被悲伤吞噬时，我们的幽默感似乎几乎无法触及，然而在悲伤和哀悼的时刻，没有什么比这更大的安慰了。在一项研究中，研究人员达克·凯尔特纳和乔治·博诺纳研究了
Absolutely. The end of our book is written with Michael Lewis. And he ends the book in the afterwards saying, when humor exists, love is not far behind. when humor exists, love is not far behind. And to your point, you know, it's true when we are consumed by grief, our sense of humor seems almost impossible to access, and yet there's no greater comfort in times of sadness and mourning. In one study, researchers at Dacker Keltner and George Bonona looked at the effects
笑声对悲痛过程的实际影响。他们招募了在过去六个月中失去亲人的人，并让他们描述与伴侣的关系。基本上发生的情况是，当研究人员回顾录像访谈时，他们发现那些表现出，你知道的，真正的笑声，你知道的，基本上大声笑出来的人，他们报告的愤怒减少了80%，痛苦比那些根本不笑的人减少了35%。那些真正开怀大笑的人还报告说，对于向前看感到明显更加积极，并且对当前社交关系的满意度也有所提高。笑声确实能减轻压力并化解紧张情绪。
of laughter actually on the bereavement process. And they recruited people who lost a loved one in the previous six months and they asked them to describe the relationship with their partner. And basically what happened was when the researchers reviewed the taped interviews, they found that when people who displayed, you know, genuine laughter, you know, basically laughed out loud, they reported 80% less anger, 35% less distress than those who, you know, didn't laugh at all. And those genuine laughers also reported feeling significantly more positive about moving forward and also increase satisfaction with their current social relationships. Laughter does decrease stress and can diffuse tension.
不仅如此，这段视频剪辑也太棒了，因为它照亮了那些搞笑的时刻——那些让你逗乐别人的时刻。它们往往照亮了你究竟是谁。科比在那一刻的真实性以一种我认为很难解释的方式流露出来，但那个简短的故事引发了笑声以及一种共识：“是的，这很合理。这就是科比。”它确实描绘了一个人真正的样子。
And more than that, that was such a great clip too because it illuminates these funny moments, those moments where you make others laugh. They often illuminate who you really are. The authenticity of Kobe in that moment came out in a way that I think would be really hard to explain, but that short story that gave rise to laughter and a common knowledge of, yeah, that makes sense. That's Kobe. I think it really does depict who one really is.
是的。你和我正在2019冠状病毒病大流行的阴影下进行这场对话。我想，我们许多人在过去的几个月里都经历过隔离有多么困难。我们知道许多人真的在受苦，许多工作失去了，许多生命消逝了。
Yeah. You and I are having this conversation in the middle of the COVID-19 pandemic. And many of us have experienced, I think, over the course of the last several months, how difficult it is to be in quarantine. We know that many people are really hurting, many jobs have been lost, many lives have been lost.
我想让你给我讲一个小故事，关于在极其漫长的一天结束时，你家里发生的事情：你丈夫已经精疲力竭，说他要去酒类专卖店买点喝的。给我讲讲当时发生的故事。我们有一个家庭群聊，我丈夫安迪在里面发了条信息。所以群里有库珀、德文、泰亚，没有麦基这只狗，但安迪说：“看起来今天很适合去葡萄酒商店买点酒。如果有人有什么要求请告诉我。”他显然是写给我看的。
I want you to tell me a little story about something that happened in your own family at the end of a very long day, your husband had come to the end of his rope and said he was gonna go out to the liquor store to get something to drink. Tell me the story of what happened. We have a family text chain, and Andy my husband texted into it. So we have Cooper Deventea on the line, not Mackie or dog, but Andy goes, it seems like a good day to stop by a wine store for some alcohol. Let me know if anyone has requests. He's obviously writing this for me.
然后15岁的泰娅说：“好的，我出一瓶最陈年、最高级的红酒的钱。”在那个时刻，它让我们所有人开怀大笑，就像是一个充满惊喜和思维急转弯的时刻。我们家庭内部的这种俏皮感在这个群聊中被激活了，真是太棒了。它确实对日常生活非常有帮助。
And 15-year-old Taya goes, OK, I'll pay for a bottle of the oldest finest red. It just brought all of us to laughter at a moment of like, it was this moment of surprise and misdirection. And the playfulness within our family that comes to life on this text string is pretty amazing. It really helps in the day to day.
你知道，有趣的是，有些人可能会说，“詹妮弗，负责任的做法是告诉你的15岁女儿，青少年喝酒对健康有害，而不是去对她摇手指。”我某种程度上能理解这种冲动从何而来。它源于对酒精成瘾等风险担忧的良好愿望。
You know, and it's interesting, you know, some people might say, well, the responsible thing to have done, Jennifer, was to tell your 15-year-old daughter that teenager's drinking alcohol is bad for their health and instead of the wag your finger at her. And I can sort of see where that impulse comes from. It comes from a good place of being worried about the risks of alcohol addiction and so forth.
但在某些时候，当我们未能展露笑容时，我们会错过幽默的可能性和幽默带来的好处。绝对是的。太有趣了。我越来越确信，让你的孩子知道他们很搞笑——即使他们的一些笑话可能脱离语境或稍微有点不合适，
But in some ways, we miss the possibilities of humor and the benefits of humor when we sometimes fail to crack a grin. Absolutely. It's so interesting. I'm increasingly convinced that making your children know that they are funny, even when some of their jokes might be out of context or slightly inappropriate,
也是你能做出的最好的育儿举措之一。想想当一个孩子知道他们逗笑了全家时，这能激发他们多少自信。当你了解你每个家庭成员的幽默风格时，笑起来也会更容易。另一个小插曲，我们的一个儿子德文，他有一种非常阴暗的幽默感，意思是像邦迪笑话、连环杀手笑话这样的话题可能会出现在他们的谈话中。
is one of the best parenting moves you can do. Think about how much confidence this inspires in a child when they know they made their family laugh. When you understand the humorous styles of each of your family members, it's also easier to laugh. Another small anecdote, one of our sons, Devon, he has a very dark sense of humor, meaning like Ted Bundy jokes, serial killer jokes can make their way into the conversation.
我从来没有真正完全理解过。在那些时刻，要开怀大笑确实很难。但一旦我理解了他的幽默风格，它与我的不同。突然之间，我们家里的事情变得更加好笑了。幽默和缓解压力的好处不仅在家里，在工作场所也是如此。我们许多人认为我们需要表现得很严肃才能被认真对待，
And I never really quite got it. It was certainly hard to laugh generously in those moments. But once I understood his humor style, I was different than mine. All of a sudden, things became even funnier at our home. The benefits of humor and relieving stress are not just in the home, but in work settings as well. Many of us think we need to be serious in order to be taken seriously,
但研究人员发现，幽默是释放创造力和生产力的强大方式。我们发现幽默在工作中被严重低估和利用不足。当人们在工作中运用幽默时——甚至不需要是多高质量的幽默，只需要是不那么不合适的幽默。这个标准太低了。他们也会被认为更有能力和自信。在另一组研究中，有幽默感的领导者，
but researchers are finding that humor is a powerful way to unlock creativity and productivity. We find that humor is completely underappreciated and under leveraged at work. When people use humor at work and it doesn't even have to be good humor, it just has to be not inappropriate humor. The bar is so low. They're also seen as more competent and confident. In another set of studies, leaders with a sense of humor,
再次强调，他们不是在搞笑，他们只是有幽默感，会被认为更有动力且更令人钦佩。我们正生活在一个信任度一直在下降的时代。在最近的一项研究中，美国进行了一项大规模研究，研究人员问人们：你更愿意信任你的老板还是一个陌生人？
again, they're not funny, they just have a sense of humor, are seen as more motivating and admired. And we're living in a time right now where trust has been on the decline. In one recent study, there was a large-scale study done in the United States, researchers asked people, would you rather trust your boss or a stranger?
58%的人回答是陌生人。真的吗？是的，信任差距很显著。而幽默的作用在于，它能让你以一种确实能培养信任的方式与某人互动。那些认为自己的老板有幽默感的员工，对工作的满意度和投入度要高出15%。
58% of the people responded stranger. Really? Yes, the trust gap is significant. And what humor does is it allows you to interact with someone in a way that does cultivate trust. And employees who rate their bosses is having a sense of humor are 15% more satisfied and engaged in their jobs.
我最喜欢的研究之一是，这项研究表明，甚至在销售推介的结尾加上一句轻松的话——比如“我的最终报价是X，我还会附赠我的宠物青蛙”——
One of my favorite studies, this was a study that shows even adding a light-hearted line at the end of a sales pitch, like my final offers X and I'll throw in my pet frog. Increases customers' willingness to pay by 18%. So you get paid more based on a bad dad joke. Again, this is where we are right now. I love that. So I want to talk for a moment about the ability that humor has to bond people together. There was a study conducted some years ago where researchers had groups of strangers watch video clips together and some of them watched neutral clips like a golf instructional video or a nature documentary. And others heard a routine from the comedian Michael McIntyre.
都能使客户的支付意愿增加18%。所以你靠一个糟糕的冷笑话赚了更多的钱。话说回来，这就是我们现在的处境。我太喜欢这个了。所以我想花一点时间谈谈幽默将人们凝聚在一起的能力。几年前曾进行过一项研究，研究人员让几组陌生人一起观看视频剪辑，其中一些人观看的是中立剪辑，比如高尔夫教学视频或自然纪录片。另一些人则听了喜剧演员迈克尔·麦金太尔的一段表演。
I particularly like Google Earth, I don't know if you've been on Google Earth, it's amazing. They photographed every road in the whole world, and they put them on Google Earth on the computer and you can go there, you just type it in, and you go there, you drag a little man over the map and you drop him into the road, and then you're there. You can see it. It's really amazing technology. And you sit in front of the computer, and you think I can go anywhere, anywhere in the world.
我特别喜欢谷歌地球，我不知道你们有没有用过谷歌地球，太神奇了。他们拍摄了全世界的每一条道路，并将它们放在电脑上的谷歌地球上，你可以去那儿，只需输入地址，然后你就能去那儿，把一个小人拖到地图上并把他放到路上，然后你就身临其境了。你可以看到它。这真的是一项了不起的技术。你坐在电脑前，心想我可以去任何地方，世界上任何地方。
Where should I go? And we all come to the same conclusion, my house. LAUGHTER So the researchers then asked all of the volunteers to write a personal note to one of the strangers in their group. People who watched the comedian were more emotionally vulnerable. They were more likely to share personal information with the stranger.
我该去哪儿？我们所有人都得出了相同的结论：我的家。笑声因此，研究人员随后要求所有的志愿者给他们组中的一个陌生人写一张便条。看过喜剧演员表演的人在情感上更加脆弱。他们更有可能与陌生人分享个人信息。
Why is it that humor makes it easier for us to bond with others, Jennifer? So when we laugh, our brains release a cocktail of healthy hormones. So it releases endorphins, same sort of hormones that are released with exercise. It reduces your cortisol, so it makes you calmer. And it also increases oxytocin, so which is the same hormone release during sex and childbirth.
詹妮弗，为什么幽默能让我们更容易与他人建立联系？当我们大笑时，我们的大脑会释放出一鸡尾酒式的健康荷尔蒙。它会释放内啡肽，这与运动时释放的荷尔蒙是同一种。它会减少你的皮质醇，从而让你更平静。它还会增加催产素，这与性爱和分娩过程中释放的荷尔蒙相同。
Both moments when evolutionarily speaking, it benefits us to feel bonded. But the big secret is that laughter also releases all of these chemicals in our brain at the same time. So it's like, you know, exercising and meditating and having sex at the same time and logistically much simpler. And for that reason, people are more likely to open up, shared laughter, or even having a sense of humor shortens the distance between two people, making them, again, as you said, you know, more
从进化论的角度来看，这两个时刻都对我们产生凝聚感大有裨益。但最大的秘密在于，笑声同时也会在我们的大脑中释放所有这些化学物质。所以这就好比，你知道的，同时进行锻炼、冥想和性爱，而且从后勤角度来看要简单得多。由于这个原因，人们更有可能敞开心扉。共同的大笑，甚至拥有幽默感，都能缩短两个人之间的距离，再次让他们像你所说的那样，（变得）更加
open to disclosing personal information. Yeah. Now, I'm afraid I can't get the image of exercising, meditating, and having sex all at the same time out of my head, so I might take a moment to get back. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Couples rated their relationship as happier when they were prompted to remember moments when they shared a laugh. So this is not just true for strangers, even when people who know each other really well, even recall times when they were laughing together,
愿意透露个人信息。是的。现在，我恐怕脑子里挥之不去“同时进行锻炼、冥想和性爱”的画面，所以我可能需要花点时间才能缓过来。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
当情侣们被提示去回忆他们共同开怀大笑的时刻时，他们对彼此关系的满意度评价会更高。所以这不仅适用于陌生人，即使是那些非常了解彼此的人，只要回想他们一起开怀大笑的时刻，
it seems like it brings them closer. This is one of my favorite studies, by the way. So couples who are asked to tell stories about moments they laugh together, versus couples who tell stories about happy moments. They report to be 23% more satisfied in their relationships. And laughter is free. And the actual mechanism behind humor is simple. Basically, it's sort of drugging you and anyone who laughs along with you. So it's like drugging others, but in a very healthy way. a very healthy way. We talked earlier about Madeline Albright using humor in 10 situations, and we also heard
似乎也能拉近彼此的距离。顺便说一句，这也是我最喜欢的研究之一。因此，那些被要求讲述他们共同开怀大笑时刻故事的情侣，与那些讲述幸福时刻故事的情侣相比，他们报告称对彼此关系的满意度高出23%。笑声是免费的。而且幽默背后的实际机制很简单。基本上，它就像是在给你以及任何和你一起笑的人“下药”。所以这就好比在给其他人下药，但却是一种非常健康的方式。一种非常健康的方式。我们之前讨论过奥尔布赖特在紧张局势中使用幽默，我们还听到了
the story of Beth Nichols, who broke up a fight at the homeless shelter where she worked. I played a bit of Beth's story for Jennifer. As they were just inches from coming to blows, I really felt like we have come to the point of no return. I had a washcloth in my hand from the kitchen and a couple inches in between them, I threw the washcloth up in the air and yelled, go for it! And they dropped their arms and they turned and stared at me with their mouths open. And everybody in the dining room was like, what? And it worked.
贝丝·尼科尔斯在工作的无家可归者收容所里平息了一场打斗的故事。我给詹妮弗放了一小段贝丝的故事。就在她们即将大打出手的前几英寸，我真的觉得我们已经到了无法挽回的地步。我手里拿着一块从厨房拿出来的抹布，在她们相隔几英寸的地方，我把抹布往空中一扔，大喊一声：“加油上吧！”她们放下了手臂，转过身来，张大嘴巴盯着我。餐厅里的所有人都觉得：“什么情况？”结果成功了。
I'm not sure that Beth actually intended to be funny in that moment, Jennifer, but her intervention revealed the absurdity of the situation. Can you talk for a moment about the role that humor plays and can play in diffusing conflict? One way to think about this is that humor is the antidote to arrogance. What's a simple thing you can do to subvert a context like Secretary Albright did or that recent example? So at the core of comedy and humor is really this idea of truth and misdirection.
詹妮弗，我不确定贝丝当时是否真的想搞笑，但她的介入揭示了当时局势的荒谬性。你能谈谈幽默在化解冲突中扮演以及可以扮演的角色吗？思考这个问题的一个方法是，幽默是傲慢的解毒剂。就像奥尔布赖特国务卿或最近的那个例子一样，你可以用来颠覆某种环境的简单事情是什么？所以喜剧和幽默的核心实际上就是关于“真相与思维误导”这个概念。
So we laugh because we think, I do that or I've seen people do that or I think I know where she's going. It's recognition of what someone is sharing. But then when you add in misdirection, where you end a story where the listener is believing you're going one way and then it reveals another, that's misdirection. And so in those cases, it can diffuse tension in very significant ways, partly because the misdirection
所以我们笑是因为我们会想：我也那样做过，或者我见过别人那样做，又或者我觉得我知道她接下来要说什么。这是对别人所分享内容的共鸣。但当你加入误导时，也就是以一种让听众以为你要往这个方向发展、结果却揭示出另一个方向的方式来结束故事，这就是误导。所以在这些情况下，它能以非常显著的方式化解紧张气氛，部分原因在于误导
creates this element of surprise, and that's essentially what you're doing with humor is you're surprising your brain and in that process, you know, tension is diffused. I'm also wondering whether part of what happened in that incident that Bethnickels describes is a process of reframing the conversation or reframing what's going on. So you have this very tense moment, Two people are almost coming to blows. Everyone around them is basically standing around their bystanders trying to figure out what to do
创造了这种惊奇的元素，而这本质上就是幽默的作用——你在给大脑一个惊喜，在这个过程中，紧张感就被化解了。我也在想，贝丝·尼克斯描述的那个事件中发生的事情，是否有一部分是重构对话或重构正在发生的事情的过程。所以你有这样一个非常紧张的时刻，两个人几乎要大打出手。周围的每个人基本上都站在那里作为旁观者，试图弄清楚该做什么
with anything to do. And then you have suddenly this person coming through a washcloth up almost like the start of a race or the launch of a boxing match or something and says, let's go. And suddenly changes the frame of what's happening. And even the audience, you know, the quote unquote, the audience sort of realizes now they're actually watching
或者能做什么。然后突然这个人走过来，挥舞着一条洗脸巾，几乎就像是一场比赛的开始，或者一场拳击赛的开场之类的，说：我们上吧。然后突然改变了事件的框架。甚至观众，你知道的，所谓的观众，某种程度上意识到他们其实是在观看
a spectacle. And it makes them sort of realize what they're doing. It makes the participants in the fight sort of step back for a second and say, Oh, I realized that there are people watching here. There's a performance that's unfolding. The reframing of what's happening, I think, is part of the reason why Beth managed to break up this fight. of what's happening, I think, is part of the reason why Beth managed to break up this fight. Absolutely. The reframe is so powerful. We have research to show that when people spontaneously reframe their stories, they're
一场奇观。这让他们意识到自己在做什么。它让争斗中的双方退后了一步，心想：哦，我意识到这里有人在看。有一场表演正在展开。我认为，对正在发生的事情进行重构，是贝丝成功化解这场争执的部分原因。我认为，对正在发生的事情进行重构，是贝丝成功化解这场争执的部分原因。当然。这种重构太强大了。我们的研究表明，当人们自发地重构自己的故事时，他们会将
the hardest stories that define their life as comedies, not only does it do things to them that make them feel better, but when they share those reframe stories, it allows the other individuals who are listening to feel closer to the individual. The example you gave me a second ago that humor is sort of this combination of exercising, meditating, and sex at the same time. I mean, it's a funny image. But one of the things that's powerful about that is that the humor allows the message to basically get in in a way that's very sticky. Many comedians use humor as an educational tool and perhaps none more than John Oliver. In last week tonight on one occasion he explained the
那些定义他们生命中最艰难的故事视为喜剧，这不仅能让他们感觉更好，而且当他们分享这些被重构的故事时，还能让倾听的其他人与当事人感到更加亲近。你刚才给我的那个例子说，幽默有点像是锻炼、冥想和性爱的结合体。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的意象。但其中强大的一点在于，幽默能让信息以一种非常深入人心的方式传达出来。许多喜剧演员将幽默作为一种教育工具，或许没有人比约翰·奥利弗更擅此道了。在《上周今夜秀》的一期节目中，他解释了
complex science of gene editing with the following description. So tonight we thought we'd take some time to talk about gene editing. What it is, what its potential could be, and what the chances are that we're all going to be killed by a 30-foot wolf. And let's start with the fact that Gina editing actually isn't new. There have been technologies like these around four years. What is new and what is driving a lot of recent coverage
基因编辑的复杂科学，并用了以下描述。所以今晚我们想花点时间聊聊基因编辑。它是什么，它的潜力在哪里，以及我们所有人被一只30英尺高的狼杀死的几率有多大。让我们从基因编辑其实并不新鲜这一点开始说起。类似的技术已经存在好几年了。什么是新的，又是什么推动了最近的大量报道
is something called CRISPR, which stands for Crunchy Reckoms in Sassy Pink Raybacks. Except it doesn't, it stands for this, but you won't remember that, and you actually don't need to. So let's go back to the Crunchy Reckoms thing. So I might never be able to think about gene editing without thinking about Crunchy Reckoms going forward, but tell me about this research that finds a link
是一种叫做CRISPR的东西，它的全称是“香脆雷康斯粉红骚气雷巴克”。其实并不是，它的全称是这个，但你记不住，其实你也不需要记住。所以我们还是回到那个“香脆雷康斯”的事情上吧。所以我以后可能再也无法想到基因编辑而不去想“香脆雷康斯”了，不过请告诉我，这项发现幽默与记忆之间联系的研究
between humor and memory and the value of humor in educational settings. Absolutely. Well, first of all, I really like the fact that this interview has changed in images in your mind, Shankar, that you will not get out ever. So I feel like our work here is done. Okay, a couple of studies that help unpack why this is so.
以及幽默在教育环境中的价值。当然。好吧，首先，我真的很喜欢这次采访在你脑海中留下的画面，香卡，这是你永远无法抹去的。所以我觉得我们这里的工作完成了。好吧，有几项研究有助于解释为什么会这样。
First, researcher Abner Ziv showed that students who were taught class material with humor retain more of it in their class learnings, scoring 11% higher on their final exams. What they did was they gave subjects humorous or non-humorous news clips. They basically designed it so that some of the news clips ended with jokes and some did not. And so in addition to collecting data on brain activity using FMRI technology, they also
首先，研究人员阿布纳·齐夫发现，通过幽默教授课堂材料的学生对课堂学习内容的保留率更高，在期末考试中的得分高出11%。他们的做法是向受试者播放幽默或非幽默的新闻短片。他们基本上这样设计：有些新闻短片以笑话结尾，有些则没有。因此，除了使用功能性磁共振成像技术收集大脑活动数据外，他们还
administered a memory test to these participants to determine how much information they retained from watching the clips. And those individuals in the humor condition retained not only significantly more information, but the elicited greater activity in the brain regions associated with thinking and cognition. So, it's one thing to say, we all need more laughter in our lives, that we need to see the humorous side of things. It's another thing, to actually be able to pull off telling a good joke. It turns out you can learn to do just that.
对这些参与者进行了记忆测试，以确定他们从观看短片中保留了多少信息。处于幽默条件下的那些个体不仅保留了显著更多的信息，而且还激发了与思考和认知相关的大脑区域更强烈的活动。所以，一方面可以说，我们所有人的生活中都需要更多的笑声，我们需要看到事物幽默的一面。另一方面，要真正能够讲好一个笑话则是另一回事。事实证明，你可以通过学习做到这一点。
We'll be back in a moment to explain how. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jennifer R. Kerr is a behavioral scientist at the Stanford Business School. As she was studying the psychology of humor, Jennifer came up with a theory that the writing of a joke is similar to what she does herself as a researcher. We have this theory that experimentation and the process that scientists use is actually strikingly similar to that which is used by comedians, right?
我们稍后回来解释如何做到。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。詹妮弗·R·科尔是斯坦福商学院的行为科学家。在研究幽默心理学时，詹妮弗提出了一种理论：编写笑话的过程与她自己作为研究人员所做的工作非常相似。我们有这样一种理论，即实验以及科学家所采用的过程，实际上与喜剧演员所采用的过程惊人地相似，对吧？
You're having hypotheses, you're observing what goes on in the real world, and then you test those hypotheses, some of us test it in the lab, and others of us test it on a stage, and you get feedback whether it be last through an audience or experimental results from participants, and you confirm
你提出假设，你观察现实世界中发生的事情，然后你验证这些假设，我们中的一些人在实验室里验证，另一些人在舞台上验证，然后你通过观众的笑声或参与者的实验结果获得反馈，以此来确认
whether your hypothesis was correct. We are not known academics are not known for our sense of humor and yet we learned so much about these secrets from comedians. You either think you're funny or you're not. There really is a elements to it. Truth and misdirection. So people think that humor is about inventing the perfect one-liner from thin air, but it's just about noticing what's true in your life. So if you just at the end of each day, write down five observations from the day, like simple things like how excited your dog is at
你的假设是否正确。我们并不以幽默感闻名，学术界不以幽默感闻名，然而我们却从喜剧演员那里学到了这么多关于这些秘密的知识。要么你认为自己很有幽默感，要么你没有。这里面确实有几个要素。真相与误导。所以人们认为幽默是从稀薄的空气中凭空捏造出完美的俏皮话，但它其实只是关于注意到你生活中的真实之处。所以如果你在每天结束时写下当天的五个观察结果，比如一些简单的事情，像你的狗在
dinner time or you know how you take a walk around the block every afternoon to break up the day or how you actually took a work call today in your underwear and then you apply these rules of misdirection which is simply just saying okay you know how do you take someone down that path of truth and then surprise or misdirect? So for example, you might say something like, the most thrilling part of my day is when I get dressed to the nines, leave my house and circle the blog just to feel something.
晚饭时有多兴奋，或者你知道你每天下午如何绕着街区散步来调剂一天，或者你今天是如何穿着内衣参加工作电话会议的，然后你运用这些误导规则，这其实很简单，就是说：好吧，你知道如何把某人带入那种通往真相的道路，然后给他们一个惊奇或误导吗？例如，你可以这样说：我一天中最惊心动魄的时刻，就是我盛装打扮，离开家，绕着街区走一圈，仅仅为了去感受点什么。
Or like contrast. So contrast is another tool you can use with misdirection. My dog seems really excited that I'm home all day now, but my cat acts like it's the apocalypse. So basically what you're doing with the misdirection is you're just taking the small little thing that you notice that's kind of, you know, interesting, not even funny. And then you're
或者像对比。所以对比是你可以与误导结合使用的另一个工具。我的狗似乎对我整天呆在家里感到非常兴奋，但我的猫表现得好像世界末日到了。所以基本上你用误导在做的事情，就是把你注意到的那个有点（你知道的）有趣、甚至谈不上好笑的小事情拿出来。然后你进行
exaggerating or contrasting it. exaggerating or contrasting it. So one of the things that you point out in the book and that you just mentioned that I thought was so insightful was that humor is often not about seeing what's funny, but about seeing what's true, about noticing the things that basically happen all around us, but most of us actually ignore. I want to play you a little clip from Comedian Jerry Seinfeld that I think illustrates both the ideas of spotting a truth but also then taking it and exaggerating that truth. Furniture, what else does that, they like car trunks? If you're trying to help people out of the pack of trunks, where does this go? Just set it down right there, it goes in some special way that only I understand.
夸大或对比。夸大或对比。所以你在书中指出并在刚才提到的一点——我认为非常有见地——就是幽默往往不是关于看到什么是好笑的，而是关于看到什么是真实的，是关于注意到那些基本上发生在我们周围，但我们大多数人却选择忽视的事情。我想给你播放一段喜剧演员杰瑞·塞恩费尔德的一小段视频，我认为它既说明了发现真相的想法，也说明了如何接受并夸大这个真相。家具，还有什么会这样，它们像汽车后备箱吗？如果你试图帮别人把东西从后备箱拿出来，这东西放哪儿？只要放下就行了，它得按某种只有我懂的特殊方式摆放。
No one could help him. Aliens could come from other galaxies to help him. He would go, would you all just let me do this place? I know what I'm doing here. And if I'm another galaxy, I think they know how to travel. Not with your mother, they don't. Just get the rest of the stuff and let me handle it here. And I feel like when I heard that, I can almost see the dad character that this person is so vivid to me. And of course, then taking that and exaggerating that with the bit about aliens is sort of spinning out that moment of truth, just sort of feel really, at this point, or galactic.
没有人能帮他。外星人从其他星系来帮他都不行。他会说：你们能不能让我来弄？我知道我在那儿做什么。如果我是另一个星系来的，我想他们知道怎么旅行。带着你妈可就不行。把剩下的东西拿过来，这儿我来处理就行了。我觉得当我听到这段话时，我几乎能看到这个父亲的形象，这个人对我来说太鲜活了。当然，然后把这一点拿来，通过关于外星人的段子进行夸大，有点像是把那个真相的时刻延伸出去，在这一点上让人感觉非常宏大或具有星际感。
is sort of spinning out that moment of truth to sort of feel really at this point or galactic. Oh, yeah, absolutely. That's exactly right. Another one that I absolutely love from Jerry Seinfeld is he has this line, Dogs are the leaders of the planet. If you see two life forms, what are they making a poop?
有点像是把那个真相的时刻延伸出去，在这一点上让人感觉非常宏大或具有星际感。哦，是的，绝对是。完全正确。另一个我绝对喜欢的杰瑞·塞恩费尔德的段子是，他有这样一句台词：狗是这个星球的领导者。如果你看到两个生命形式，一个在拉屎，
The other one's carrying it for him. Who would you assume is in charge? There's these really simple ways to get from setup to punchline, using this misdirection idea. Yeah. There's also a very important humor principle that we learned from improv. The actotina Faye once sat down with former Google CEO, Eric Schmidt, and taught him a comedy technique. They start out here by acting out an improvised scene.
另一个帮它捡起来。你会认为谁在掌控一切？这些是非常简单的方法，通过使用这个误导的想法，从铺垫过渡到笑点。是的。还有一个非常重要的幽默原则，我们是从即兴表演中学到的。演员蒂娜·菲曾与前谷歌首席执行官埃里克·施密特坐在一起，教他一个喜剧技巧。他们通过表演一个即兴场景从这里开始。
Stop. I've got a gun. The gun? The gun I gave you for our wedding anniversary, Eric. How could you? We're not married. Aha. We're not married as a denial.
停。我有一把枪。枪？我送给你的结婚纪念日礼物的枪，埃里克。你怎么能这样？我们没结婚。啊哈。我们没结婚是一个否定。
We've learned our first improv lesson. Talk about the principle of yes and Jennifer. One of the first rules of improv comedy is the concept of yes and. So that's simply the rule that when you're a scene partner, you know, Eric Schmidt, makes an offer, you know, either explicitly or implicitly, you always agree with a premise
我们学到了第一堂即兴表演课。谈谈“是的，而且”原则，詹妮弗。即兴喜剧的第一条规则之一就是“是的，而且”的概念。这其实就是这样一条规则：当你是场景伙伴时，你知道的，埃里克·施密特提出了一个提议（无论是明确的还是隐含的），你总是同意这个前提，
and then you add something new to it. And so when you're trying to actually create a context where humor can thrive, that basic principle of yes and is really important to lay down as sort of one of the norms. So we've talked about a number of different ideas here. We've talked about the idea of the importance of spotting truth, the value of exaggeration. I want to play you a clip from the comedian, Ellen DeGeneres, that really brings together many of these techniques. And I'm going to play the clip and have our listeners try to spot the elements of the different techniques
然后在此基础上增加一些新的东西。因此，当你试图真正创造一个能够让幽默蓬勃发展的语境时，“是的，而且”这一基本原则作为规范之一是非常重要需要确立的。所以我们在这里讨论了许多不同的观点。我们讨论了发现真相的重要性的观点，以及夸大的价值。我想播放一段喜剧演员埃伦·德杰尼勒斯的短片，它真正汇集了许多这些技巧。我要播放这段短片，让我们的听众试着找出埃伦在这里使用的不同技巧的元素
that Ellen is using here. So it's been 15 years since I've done stand-up and when I decided to do this special, a friend of mine was at my house and I told him, I'm going to do stand-up and when I decided to do this special, a friend of mine was at my house, and I told him I'm going to do stand-up again. And he said, really? And I said, yeah, I was hoping for more of a really, but it was really. And I said, yes, why? And he said, well, do you think you're still relatable? I said, yes, I do think I'm still relatable.
。所以自我做单口喜剧已经过去了15年，当我决定做这个特别节目时，我的一个朋友在我家，我告诉他：“我要做单口喜剧。”当我决定做这个特别节目时，我的一个朋友在我家，我告诉他我要重新开始做单口喜剧。他说：“真的吗？”我说：“对，我希望听到更多一声‘真的吗’，但它确实是‘真的’。”我说：“是的，为什么？”他说：“哦，你觉得你现在还接地气吗？”我说：“是的，我觉得我依然很接地气。
I'm a human being. And anyway, just then Batu, my butler, stepped into the library. And he announced that my breakfast was ready. And I was on my third or fourth bite of cube pineapple that Batu was feeding me. And I said, Batu, I'm not hungry. I've lost my appetite. My friend has really upset me by what he said.
我是个人类。”总之，就在这时，巴图，我的管家，走进了书房。他宣布我的早餐准备好了。当时我正吃着巴图喂给我的第三或第四块切块菠萝。我说：“巴图，我不饿。我没有胃口了。我朋友的话让我很难过。”
And he said, well, then I shall draw you a bath-mem. And so I'm sitting in the tub, and I'm looking out the window with the rose garden. And anyway, I get out of the tub, and Betu had forgotten to put the towel next to the tub again. So I had to do that bath mat scoot all the way across the bathroom to get to the towel. And it's a big, you can imagine how big the bathroom is. It's like doing the bath mat scoot. And then I I stopped and I was like, oh my God,
他说：“好吧，那我给您放洗澡水吧。”于是我坐在浴缸里，看着窗外的玫瑰园。总之，我从浴缸里出来，而巴图又忘了把毛巾放在浴缸旁边了。所以我不得不一路踩着浴垫在浴室里挪动，才能拿到毛巾。这是一个大浴室，你可以想象浴室有多大。就像做浴垫滑行一样。然后我停下来，心想：天哪，
this is relatable. So Jennifer, walk me through what Ellen just did there. Okay, so first, what she does really well in general, but definitely in that clip is understanding what people are feeling and naming that thing. So the whole title of the tour, you know, relatable and that entire first sketch is basically enaming what people are feeling and thinking. Second, she uses exaggeration.
这太接地气了。所以詹妮弗，带我回顾一下埃伦刚才在那里做了什么。好的，首先，她在总体上做得很好，在这个短片中绝对也是如此，那就是理解人们的感受并将其命名出来。所以整个巡演的标题，你知道的，“接地气”，以及整个第一个小品，基本上就是在为人们的感受和想法命名。其次，她使用了夸张。
So she kind of builds out that world. And what she's doing is she's saying like, if that's true, what else is true? So for example, when she says, you know, if it's true that she has a butler named bat two, what else is true? The salarium, the rose garden, drawing a bath. And so you're painting out this world based on that simple exaggeration.
所以她有点构建出那个世界。而她所做的是，她说：如果这是真的，还有什么也是真的？例如，当她说（你知道的）如果她有一个名叫巴图的管家这件事是真的，还有什么也是真的？日光浴室、玫瑰园、放洗澡水。所以你根据那个简单的夸张描绘出了这个世界。
She's often ending on funny. She's just got a remarkable sense of timing, like when to say basically, again, you know. And then I think the other thing is the self-deprecation and self-awareness. We show that individuals that use self-deprecation, especially in high status, contacts, you know, have an incredible ability to shorten the distance between them and the audience.
她经常以搞笑收尾。她有着卓越的时机感，比如什么时候再次说出“基本上，又来了”（你知道的）。然后我认为另一件事是自嘲和自我觉察。我们表明，使用自嘲的个人，尤其是在高地位的环境中，（你知道的）具有一种不可思议的能力，能够缩短他们与观众之间的距离。
It makes people much more approachable. So that level of self-awareness, she let gleam in there was also really powerful because it also, like the physical elements of it, like the bathmat scoot was just fantastic. She also does something here that you alluded to earlier in our conversation, which is the sketch starts with this friend of hers questioning whether she's still relatable. By the time we come back to that, it's actually about 60 seconds into the joke that we come back to that.
这让人显得平易近人得多。因此，她流露出的那种自我觉察水平也非常强大，因为这也——就像其中的身体元素一样，比如浴垫滑行，简直太棒了。她在这里还做了一件事，你在我们对话的早期曾暗示过，那就是小品以她的一个朋友质疑她是否还接地气开始。等我们回到这个话题时，其实已经是笑话开始大约60秒之后了。
At that point, we realized this whole thing actually is part of the same unit. The whole thing is actually one setup for coming back to that original idea. You talked about the idea of callbacks earlier, the idea of sort of circling back and finding connections. Can you talk about that, not just from the point of view, what makes a joke work, but from the point of view
在那一刻，我们意识到整件事其实都是同一个整体的一部分。整件事实际上都是一个铺垫，最终为了回到最初的那个想法。你之前谈到了回调的想法，也就是兜圈子并寻找联系的想法。你能谈谈这一点吗？不仅从让笑话起效的角度，而是从以下角度：
of how callbacks in some ways bond people together and give them a sense of being part of a shared experience. Absolutely. So callbacks are very simple things. They're basically just when, you know, if you're in a meeting or in any context and someone makes a joke, and then later in the meeting you reference, you anchor on that laugh line and you simply call back to it. Her ability in that sketch to call back to her friend and then she had multiple callbacks about the butler is really powerful. What happens when you do it, when all of us do it, is that you make the person who originally
回调在某种程度上如何将人们凝聚在一起，并赋予他们一种作为共同体验一部分的感觉？当然。所以回调是非常简单的事情。它们基本上就是，你知道的，如果你在一个会议中或在任何语境下，有人开了一个玩笑，然后在会议的后期你引用、锚定那个笑点并简单地回调它。她在那个短片中回调她的朋友，然后她对管家有多次回调，这非常有力。当你这样做时，我们所有人这样做时，会让你最初
had the laugh line feel good, feel listen to, I see you, I heard you. It really actually helps to create this inclusive environment. So, we've talked a lot about the upside of humor in the workplace, but I wonder what knowledge there are, there are reasons many companies have clamped down on jokes in professional settings. You mentioned that this happened to you yourself in college where you, you know, you had a joke about a friend and the friend thought that you were being hurtful or that you were being mean-spirited. So what's funny to you might not be not only not funny to me, it could actually be offensive to me. Jennifer, how do you draw a line between all the good things that
抖出笑点的那个人感觉良好、感觉被倾听：“我看见你了，我听见你了”。这实际上确实有助于创造这种包容性的环境。所以，我们讨论了很多关于职场中幽默的积极一面，但我想知道有哪些认识，为什么许多公司在职业场合对笑话采取了严厉打击的态度。你提到这在大学里发生在你身上，当时你（你知道的）开了一个关于朋友的玩笑，而朋友认为你是在伤害别人或者你是不怀好意。所以对你来说好笑的事情，可能不仅对我来说不好笑，甚至可能对我有冒犯性。詹妮弗，你如何在幽默带来的所有美好事物与它可能带来的问题之间划一条线，尤其是在职场中？
human does and the problematic things that can do, especially in the workplace? One way to think about how do you avoid the risks associated with humor, or how do you actually recover if there is a humor misstep, belies in this framework of truth, pain, and distance. The idea is that truth is the heart of comedy. So we laugh at, as you said, what we recognize. But at the same time, the truth coupled with pain and not enough distance may come across as insensitive or hurtful or offensive.
思考如何避免与幽默相关的风险，或者如果出现幽默失误如何真正恢复的方法之一，在于“真相、痛苦和距离”这一框架。这个想法是，真相是喜剧的核心。所以正如你所说，我们嘲笑我们所识别的东西。但与此同时，真相如果伴随着痛苦且缺乏足够的距离，可能会显得麻木不仁、伤人或具有冒犯性。
If you remove humor from the one line that you created, and the truth of that statement still stands, there is integrity in actually what you're saying. And so when you have to say something like, I'm just joking, you know you've lost it. Another rule that we talk about is like never punch down. And so that idea of using humor on someone within the organization that has lower levels of status, there's no faster way to lose an audience. I understand that your mom used to be a hospice volunteer and she would sometimes tell you stories at the end of the day about the regrets of the dying.
如果你从你创作的那句台词中去掉幽默，而该陈述的真相依然成立，那么你所说的话就具有正直性。因此，当你不得不说类似“我只是开玩笑”这样的话时，你就知道你已经失去了它。我们讨论的另一条规则是：永远不要向下开玩笑。因此，对组织内地位较低的人使用幽默这一想法，是没有比这更快失去观众的方法了。我听说你的母亲以前是一名临终关怀志愿者，她有时会在一天结束时给你讲一些关于垂死之人的遗憾的故事。
Why don't you tell you Jennifer? Yeah, so she actually still is. She's done more than 40 years of volunteering at hospice. And so we grew up, I'm the oldest of two other sisters, and so we would grow up listening to stories of what people wish for in their last days of life, because we're a fun family. And one of the things that we learned is,
詹妮弗，你为什么不给我们讲讲呢？是的，她实际上现在仍然是。她做了超过40年的临终关怀志愿者。所以我们在成长过程中——我是三个姐妹中的老大——我们伴随着倾听人们在生命最后几天的心愿的故事长大，因为我们是一个有趣的家庭。我们学到的事情之一就是，
is people wish for simple things. Like, I wish I didn't take myself so seriously. I wish I let myself laugh more, which is remarkable because it's being expressed in one of the most serious meaningful moments of one's life. People wish that they had been more present, that they just savored the here and now. And what we find with humor is that you're forced to be very present. When you prioritize humor, you're listening for those callbacks. You're listening to those moments of truth that are being revealed. And so it allows you to cultivate joy in a very present way. And as we started this interview, Michael Lewis really, I think, captures the gist of what
人们渴望一些简单的事情。比如：我希望我没有对自己那么严肃。我希望我能让自己多笑一笑。这很了不起，因为它是在一个人一生中最严肃、最有意义的时刻之一被表达出来的。人们希望自己能更加活在当下，能够细细品味此时此地。而我们通过幽默发现的是，你被迫变得非常活在当下。当你优先考虑幽默时，你是在倾听那些回调。你是在倾听那些正在被揭示的真相时刻。因此，它能让你以一种非常当下的方式培养快乐。正如我们开始这次采访时那样，迈克尔·刘易斯 realmente（确实）——我认为——抓住了我们
we're trying to create and communicate when he says, when humor exists, love is not far behind. And there's, you know, few acts as easy and generous as sharing laughter with someone. So I think at the end of the day, the reason this work is so important is because it helps to encapsulate what's truly meaningful in life. Jennifer Acker is a behavioral scientist at the Stanford Business School. Along with Naomi Bagnones, she is co-author of the book, Humor Seriously. Jennifer, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
试图创造和传达的核心，他说：“当幽默存在时，爱就不远了。”而且你知道的，很少有比和某人分享笑声更简单、更慷慨的行为。所以我认为归根结底，这项工作之所以如此重要，是因为它有助于概括生命中真正有意义的东西。詹妮弗·阿克尔是斯坦福商学院的行为科学家。她与娜奥米·巴格诺内斯合著了《严肃的幽默》一书。詹妮弗，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, Kristen Wong, and Laura Quarell. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Lawrence Goodworth, who works for just works, the company that handles payroll for Hidden
《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、奥特曼·巴恩斯、莱恩·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克、克里斯滕·王和劳拉·夸雷尔。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是劳伦斯·古德沃思，他为Justworks工作，该公司负责处理《隐藏的大脑》传媒的薪资。我们最近对设置休假和病假政策的方式有一些疑问。它们很复杂，而劳伦斯耐心地与我们一起梳理，解释了诸如结转和累积上限等细节。感谢你的耐心和对细节的关注，劳伦斯。在我们离开之前还有最后一件事，我们正在做一个关于选择的故事。我们如何做出选择，以及我们回首时如何看待它们。有没有什么你做过的大型改变人生的选择，
Brain Media. We recently had some questions about the way we had set up our vacation and sick leave policies. They were complicated, and Lawrence patiently went through them with us, explaining the minutiae of things like carryover and a cruel caps. Thank you for your patience and attention to detail Lawrence. One last thing before we go, we are working on a story about choices. How we make choices and how we think of them looking back. Are there big life-changing choices you've made
如果你今天来做会做出不同的决定？你当初为什么做出那个选择？你年轻时的自己对今天的你是谁，或者对那个决定的永久性有什么不理解的地方？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这样的故事，找一个安静的房间，在手机上录制一条语音备忘录。三到四分钟就足够了。将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org，并使用主题行：
that you would make differently today? Why did you make that choice? What did your younger self not understand about who you are today or about the permanence of that decision? If you're willing to share a story like that with a hidden brain audience, find a quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Three to four minutes is plenty. Email it to us at ideasathydnBrain.org and use a subject line,
选择。请务必附上你的全名以及一个电话号码，如果我们决定采用你的故事，我们可以通过它联系到你。再次强调，电子邮件地址是：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。下周见。我喜欢这次采访。我喜欢你有一些
choices. Make sure to include your full name and a phone number where we can reach you if we decide to feature your story. Again, that email address is ideas at HiddenBrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. I love this interview. I love the fact that you have some images. You can't get rid of. Yeah, I'm now half the combination of crunchy rectums and meditating, exercising, and having sex at the same time. Oh my gosh. Can we just put that in as the blooper reel? Hahaha! you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
挥之不去的画面。是的，我现在是一半“香脆雷康斯”和一半冥想、锻炼外加性爱的结合体。哦天哪。我们能把它放进NG花絮集锦里吗？哈哈哈！这个单集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。